the CGI is too much it's the whole
movies now it's everything I don't
believe anything There's no practical
what James did with like you know when
she's soury and the aliens is walking in
that thing that like yellow everything
he did was with Miniatures and this they
don't do that anymore it's CGI it's
previs it's like all planned out previs
should get directing credit for half the
movies that are out there and they're
everything is CGI so I I'm answering
that for me I think it's lacking because
there's too much CGI you know a lot of
people feel the way that you do is
there's too much of that stuff too much
there's so much content out there uh for
me it's hard for me to follow the last
thing that I saw I took my son to see uh
Spider-Man the universe or something
animated unbelievable I had not
seen any I had I had not seen an
animated movie since Lion King